[موسيقى]
نحن خلصنا من الموت كتبنا حياه تانيه
تاريخ عم بيعيد نفسه كتير مريضه
مرحبا عاد مسلسل الموت هذا العام بجزء
الثالث وعلى مقياس الجماهيري لم يستطع
العمل ان يحظى بنفس التفاعل اللي حدا به
خلال الموسمين السابقين على مواقع التواصل
طبعا مع عوده البطلتين ماجي بوصن ودانيلا
رحمه من الموت وغياب عدد من اهم ابطال
للعمل سابقا ابرزهم باسم مغنيه مسلسل
للموت وكاراكتير سحر كم مصري اعطاني كتير
اعطاني كتير على الصعيد المهني وعلى
الصعيد الشخصي انا هيدي الشخصيه حبيتها
واتعلمت منها القوه تعلمت منها كتير وعلى
الصعيد المهني حتني بمحل
اعلى يمكن من المحل خطوط خطوات لقدام في
كان منافس شرس للموت وصل للعالميه حتى عم
يترجم عم يتدبلج وعم يترجم لعده لغات وعم
ينحدر بكل دول العالم وهذا الشيء بكبر
القلب صراحه تاتي احداث مسلسل للموت للجزء
الثاني في رمضان اللي تكمل احداث الجزئين
السابقين في اطار متصل ومنفصل في ذات
الوقت حيث يشارك في الجزء الثالث الشخصيات
جديده باحداث دراميه مثيره عفتنا بمحل في
تنوع كثير كبير في شخصيات كتير جديده
وشخصيات مش بس فايتين هيك يعني مش شخصيات
بتمرق مرور الكرام لا في شخصيات عن جد
فعلا حتعلم هالسنه اللي مكتوب كتير حلو
التصوير والانتاج
والتونس رحنا على تونس وصورنا
بتوينوس مشاهد رائعه كل العوامل هيك ثقيله
هالسنه هي دراما عربيه فيها اكثر من جنسيه
هي بالنسبه لالنا انا بعتبرها لان انا
بتعلم من غيره بتعلم مني فهيدا الاختلاط
هو اللي بخليك انت يقيم عندك
نضج لانك انت عم تشوف الاخر والاخر عم
بيشوفك العمل هو بسبب جزئيه السابقين
وجماهيريه ابطاله استطاع الحفاظ على عدد
كبير من جمهوره بالاضافه لفئه جديده فماذا
قال الجمهور للموت عن هذا الجزء تحديدا
[موسيقى]
الحياه مثل البيانو
تاخدي منها
بعد ما بتعرفي